[Musik]
hallo papa analyse junger männer
sie sind nico ja ich heiße nicolas ganz
anders hat man es freut mich sehr
setzen sie sich doch bitte wie gern
helfen wie ist ihr geburtsdatum ich
meine wann haben sie geburtstag
geburtstag geburtstag adresse wir nehmen
eine adresse ich wohne in der
wagnergasse 136 ihre passnummer
passnummer mein pass ist weg oh das ist
nicht gut
dass es jahre und der ist ja und seine
tante sarah ist ihre tante ja wohl jahre
haben sie eine adresse ist ja informiert
dass sie hier sind
sandra weiss nicht warum hier ist ein
puzzle gelöst und ich weiß es nicht aber
ich jetzt rausfinden
ich helfe dir danke papa gerne
telefonieren hat viel spaß handball
party party
[Musik]